what's up guys hey i was just wondering
how do i know if you're not a deep fake
oh gang gang this is gonna uh
this is gonna happen five years from now
that'll be a real
legit thing what what is it someone's
already fakes so a lot of it's like yeah
it's it's funny when i'm watching the
characters it's like
i when i'm watching your characters i
feel like i'm watching them
i know it's your creativity behind it
but i feel like i'm watching them most
of the time
you know it's funny i don't use the deep
fake technology that's really good
mine is a shitty janky thing because i
found
that the real deep fake is creepy and
not funny like
the wrong side of your brain is is
freaked out when it's
close to the person yeah like i don't
know if you've seen the
real deep fake ones that look really
good have you seen those i think i've
seen some of them
i got one of uh tom cruise yeah like
this
so that's my friend miles fisher dude is
that right
yeah he's killing him you know reminds
me
once in the russia he ran into
uh gorbachev look it's amazing
but that's a really good deep fake
that's not a defect this is
no that's deeper that's not tough
god that's amazing remember but this
isn't that's just him he looks like this
but they they just put his face on it
they put tom cruise's face on him he
already does a good impression
himself oh okay but the defense people
he's fooled like a bunch of people
there's
he's got a tick tock account that's like
good for him it's
amazing but anyway it's um i find it's
not as funny yeah comedy doesn't work
when your brain is like wait something's
wrong here
it's like the brain needs to know
something's wrong yeah just so we can
uncomfortable
and relax like south park looks really
goofy
um and the face swap thing i have looks
very goofy it's clearly like kind of
broken but that
i did a common essential pilot and we
used this extreme deep fake and it was
like creepy
it was wow it wasn't funny they didn't
pick it up huh
no hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you